[Musik]
bismark erst ist platin blm juni kämpfe
zwischen klassischer antike und
spätantike es ist schon gängig dass
historiker nicht flüssig sondern einfach
historiker auch von einer hektischen
zeit sprechen uns verwenden das mehr
oder weniger gleich wie viel los ist die
historiker denke zum beispiel sieht man
mal von der himmel schießen zeit
zwischen dem tod das alles andere ist
der größte der gold den größen und
leopard tod von cleopatra also grob vom
vierten bis 1 ersten jahrhundert vor
christus und in der plus sie geschichte
ist dass die von dieser zeit zu starten
weil wir genau in dieser zeit die
entstehung und entwicklung von den
sogenannten hessischen schulen haben
nämlich die story korea und skeptiker
auch andere wie zum beispiel die zyniker
das sind die halter also die drei
hauptschulen sind die erste teil dann zu
werden älter und so weiter spielen auch
eine rolle
dann in der spätantike also ab dem
dritten jahrhundert nach christus haben
wir eine sehr starke tendenzen der fluss
wie die wir neue tourismus nennen neue
platten es müssen vor einem profi rios
werden wir nächste woche besprechen
in der zeit zwischen der hessischen
periode und der spätantike haben wir ein
zeitalter was erstens sowieso von fotos
videos oder kann er abgewertet wird oder
generiert wird oft und auch eine zeit
die nicht unbedingt sein
bezeichnung hat auch normale geschichte
aber wenn sie ein wissen über
europäische geschichte kennen natürlich
ist das die zeit der entstehung des
komischen römischen imperiums also grob
gesagt können es könne sie denken okay
es gibt die welt nacht alexander den
großen also er hat von griechenland bis
zentralasien erobert dass es ein reich
zerfällt in drei bereiche nachdem er
stirbt und die zeit wo diese drei
bereiche kann man auch an der macht sind
dass es eine lesbische pluscity werden
das kommt rum in boston auf saison wird
zunehmend mächtig und erinnert an
griechenland syrien nahost
die jetzigen ausländer und wir haben
dann beim römischen imperium etwa ab dem
ersten jahrhundert vor christus erste
jahrhundert nach christus ersten
jahrhundert vor christus ist natürlich
auch nützlich weil es ist natürlich der
übergang von der römischen republik ins
römische imperium
und wie gesagt ist das philosophisch
auch einleuchtend weil wir zuerst diese
hellenistischen schulen haben danach in
der spätantike in optimismus haben und
in der mitte eine zeit die etwas
verschwommen ist da sind erstens sind
unsere texte nicht jemand so wie wir es
gerne haben würden auch für die
klassische zeit aber das ist natürlich
ein zeitalter von zum beispiel cicero
seneca marco d effekt also die römische
historiker und ja auch der haupt
skeptiker der antike sagt dass imperiums
den ich bald bin haben auch erwähnt wird
werde
allerdings ist das nicht nur eine
ausdehnung der hessische los ist weil
wir ab dem ersten jahrhundert vor
christus oder so
zunehmend interesse an platon und
aristoteles unter den philosophen senden
zum beispiel der beste antike
kommentator zu
das sagte alexander von alicias den
zweiten jahrhunderts wir haben in dieser
zeit ist die sogenannte mittel
platonischer zb kinos nominierten von
alexandrien ein jüdischer platonischer
also diese und manchmal wird diese zeit
von mindestens vier sind desto eher kann
wird das zunehmend oft post heller ist
sicher city genannt also sozusagen
zwischen story historiker als skeptiker
und mein plan erst mal meinen könnte
vielleicht passe wie wir diese zeit
denken als eine zeit wo die drei
hellenistischen die steuerbefehle und
skeptiker gleichzeitig mit platten
platon und aristoteles existieren
danach ab dem dritten jahrhundert vor
allem durch platin werden hessische
schulen besiegt die sterben mehr oder
weniger völlig aus und alle für das
offen sind platonischer die auch gerne
dass dort ließ lesen sehen sich aber gar
nicht aus zucker oder so und
gleichzeitig ab dem 3
das ist auch irgendwie an hilfreich wenn
man diese wenn man die zeit so
erschüttert dass christliche philosophie
mehr oder weniger hat den zweiten oder
dritten jahrhundert nach christus dann
anfängt also julian dann augustinus die
kapitel und so weiter dies sind
gleichzeitig in der spätantike mit den
nationalisten also grob kann man antike
floss wie nach der klassischen zeit so
einordnen oder klassifizieren
alles natürlich alles ein bisschen
künstlich und nein das kann man so
machen wie man welt aber wahrscheinlich
dass
also heute es ist unser anliegen tiere
vor allem bei diesen helens in schulen
zu besprechen
allerdings werden wir wieder das problem
haben was wir bei den vorschlag artikeln
hatten nämlich dass die texte in der
regel völlig verschieden sind wir haben
keine gänzliche texte erhaltenen texte
von den früheren story kann zb presse
donnerstag
sie haben texte verfasst die wir
geschrieben
diese texte sind aber verloren wenn nur
durch spätere belege bekannt
also berichtet estonian und wenn wir
glück haben auch zitate sehr nützlich
ist als quelle ist sitze im ersten
jahrhundert vor christus der sehr
ausführliche werke auf latein geschieden
hat wo er die herrlichste die schulen
beschreibt und sogar dialoge scheint wo
verschiedene sprecher dann auftauchen
und die ansichten der historiker und so
weiter verteidigen sie zwar skeptiker
sogar ein akademisches katic skeptiker
die platte die akademie von platon würde
in der hendersons skeptisch ein paar
nicht dogmatisch thematisches platin ist
es kommt eine der später entwickelte
zurück oder sogar in der preußischen
zeit zurück und siehst du gehört zu
dieser tradition
das heißt philosophen die vermeiden
wollen irgendwelche dogmen oder sogar
ansichten zu haben sie betrachten alle
philosophische thesen skeptisch
durchschnittlich aber genau deswegen war
es für besitzer interessant
all diese philosophische theorien zu
beschreiben darzustellen damit er sieht
einen widerlegen konnte wurde damit er
zeigen könnte konnte dass die
verschiedenen schulen gute argumente
gegeneinander hatten und von daher ist
cicero eine hauptquelle
für hessische philosophie des imperiums
der spätere skeptiker der chronische
skeptiker war auch diese auch eine sehr
wichtige quelle für uns und aus dem
zweiten jahrhundert nach christus eine
dritte quelle ist die organisation
er war vielleicht kann eigentlich kein
philosoph aber ein langes werk
geschrieben über die biografien der
philosophen berichtet wo die die
philosophen gelebt haben was sie gemacht
haben und dann beschreibt auch die lehre
der verschiedenen philosophen bei platon
oder alt das doppel ist zum beispiel ist
das nicht so nützlich also da haben wir
legen ein paar anekdoten über das leben
ist schon interessant und vielleicht ab
und zu sogar war aber was wirklich sehr
wichtig und nützlich ist sind seine
beschreibungen von denen lernen der
verschiedenen sperrliste den schulen
das scheint mehr oder weniger wichtig zu
sein es wieder eine hauptquelle die zum
beispiel haben ergänzen oder bestätigen
kann
und dann gibt es auch wieder kleine zum
beispiel bei den markierten feld
berichten auch ein bisschen über was
früher gesagt haben usw charismas haben
wir glück zweierlei erstens gibt es zwei
werke von epikur die bei der
organisation ausführlich einfach kopiert
auftauchen also er zitiert wortwörtlich
ganze briefe von epicor und das ist
unsere beste quelle für die die
ansichten von apple tourismus dann haben
wir natürlich auch lucretia ein
zeitgenosse von cicero der ein langes er
geschrieben hat an handwerker ein einer
eines werks von epicor auf latein was
gedeckt was
dieses neue werk von epicor als dicht
schon dann weiter gibt also irgendwie
ironisch
meiner meinung nach war es zu besitzen
was eigentlich dominante in dieser zeit
als apple kölner erstmals und das sieht
man daran dass die römischen philosophen
die erhalten sind vorwiegend story cars
etc neckar und so weiter kann die sind
keine apple korea diesen krebs man sieht
dass in der aristokratischen kreisen
länge dadurch ist das krad in den
kreisen
das muss vielleicht besser aufgenommen
würde
als doris muss aber die texte für apple
tourismus sind etwas besser als das
tourismus und dann würde das übrigens
alles in der renaissance neu entdeckt
zum beispiel dieses gedicht über die
natur der dinge
von lukas würde in dem 15 jahrhundert
buchstäblich neu entdeckt in einer
handschrift die seit jahrhunderten nicht
gelesen würde und dann haben wir sie das
angefangen das zu melden und gesagt oh
mann das ist die lateinische sprache in
diesem gedeckt ist sehr sehr schön also
den vorbildern wie wir dateien verwenden
sollen leider sind die jobs inge etwas
seitlich und problematisch und dann
hatten sie dieses problem was sollen wir
mit solchen texten machen die
offensichtlich heidnisch sind
durchaus
aber sprachlich ist sehr schön
vielleicht werde ich dann noch mal was
dazu sagen wenn wir das was sie
erreichen und für das tourismus ist die
situation ähnlich skeptizismus ist die
situation ähnlich die größte skeptiker
sind verloren also die werke sind
verloren wir haben aber dann später
durch die bei cicero bei diogenes wollte
auch bei sagt dass der ersatz der tiger
war und der sehr ausführliche argumente
für skeptizismus bietet okay so diese
drei schulen haben alle gemeinsam dass
sie uns von light oder altacher der
verein wollen taraki heißt so was sie
die aufregung oder paar also wenn man
nichts nicht ruhig erst unruhe
die wollen uns von uns unruhe befreien
dadurch dass sie philosophische
argumente anbieten die unsere fürchten
probleme irgendwie lösen oder ablösen
können
vielleicht soll ich mit den trainern
anfangen also die apple korea sagen
diesen hätte westen hätte größer als
bauherrin ist und erklärt dass man wenn
man nur wenn man bewusst ist dass nur
lust wichtig ist und wenn man sieht wie
leicht es ist lust zu erreichen ohne
schmerz zu vermeiden dass man dann
unruhe erreicht
wieso
weil man wenn man sich kranke für uns
sehr wenig zu nötig zu haben also wenig
essen wein trinken wenn man sich daran
gewöhnt wenn ich mit wenig geld
auszukommen
wenn man sich dran gewöhnt keine kinder
zu haben vielleicht sogar keine sexuelle
beziehungen zu haben
wenn man keine erde oder andere und
natürliche lustobjekte zu wollen
dann kommt man mit sehr wenig sehr gut
aus und das ist apple touristische hätte
das muss also das heißt man gewöhnt sich
dran was nichts zu brauchen und dadurch
erreicht man dass man keine unerfüllte
wünsche hat und deswegen leidet man
nichts trennen also legal buddhismus
das ist aber ein falscher eindruck weil
die buddhisten sagen nicht dass wir sehr
sehr sehr bescheidene wünsche haben
sollen sie sagen dass wir überhaupt
keine wünsche haben sollen
die ecke gehen davon aus dass wir
natürlich wünsche haben und dass wir
natürlich lust uns ja immer nach stehen
werden
aber wenn wir verlieren mit hilfe der
apple klinischen floss können wir uns
daran gewöhnen mit fast nichts zufrieden
zu sein und in dieser zufügen als
besteht oder die abwesenheit der unruhe
besser gesagt attraktion ist das
griechische wort ähnlicher weise die
historiker wir erreichen hat sachsen
ja wir sind herr unruhe dadurch dass wir
lernen dass die götter oder ein gott die
ganze welt führt mit göttlicher vorhält
vorhersehen steuert und dass alles gut
ist so wie es ist auch wenn es für
einzelne menschen anscheinend schlecht
wirst das heißt dass man lernt da ist
man akzeptieren muss
das zum beispiel
ein familienmitglied von einer krankheit
stirbt oder sogar dass man selbst stirbt
das alles gewollt sei es dass das so aus
der perspektive der ganzen welt und
deswegen soll man immer mit dem was
passiert zufrieden sein
deswegen sagen wir immer noch dass
jemand eine stoische einstellung hat
weil er oder sie mit unglück dann gut
auskommen kann oder einmal akzeptieren
kann die strecke haben beraten dass wir
alles einfach akzeptieren sollen so wie
es ist weil es so von gott gewollt war
dadurch erreicht man nochmal in
abwesenheit der unruhe
also die skeptiker vor allem bei sextus
impressions rassismus da würde man sich
vielleicht wundern dass sie auch dass
sie das auch anbieten können oder dass
sie das auch versprechen uns von unruhe
zu befreien wie sollten wir uns von
unruhe befreien nur dadurch dass wir
keine ansichten oder dortmund
akzeptieren
antwort was uns immer stört ist dass die
ist mit sicherheit ein sichere
überzeugung erreichen und bis wir das
erreichen haben wir irgendwie hermann
mindestens im hinterkopf unzufriedenheit
weil wir nicht genau wissen wie die welt
ist also haben dieses streben oder
verlangen die welt besser zu verstehen
was bei den automatischen philosophen
durchaus richtig ist und in ordnung und
von auch bei skeptisch als natürlich und
irgendwie unvermeidlich geschrieben wird
allerdings wenn wir dann die die
untersuchungen für das so für
untersuchungen nach um die wir das
überstehen skeptiker heißt übrigens als
skeptikers heißt diejenigen die
untersuchen oder die suchen
das gab's das heißt suche
und wenn man eine untersuchung macht in
die philosophische ansichten man sieht
dass alle argumente bei hanna viele
solchen schulen platonischer dass de
telegraaf historiker die sind alle wie
es das immer sagt ihm gleich gerichts
das heißt sie sind überall genauso stark
auf einer seite wie auf der anderen
seite und wenn man das sieht kann man
die eigene überzeugung nur enthalten
und dann entsteht weil man denkt okay
also ich kann sowieso nicht verstellen
was der fall ist also das irgendwie
entspannen zu wissen dass ich nicht
nicht wissen kann
allerdings ist das nicht ganz richtig
dass ich gesagt habe war sechster es
auch früher die skeptiker hätten das
wahrscheinlich gesagt dass ich mein ziel
als skeptiker ist zu verstehen dass ich
nichts wissen kann wenn's sechster
damit er konsequent leid sagt ich bin
skeptisch der frage gegenüber ob ich
wissen erreichen kann oder nicht
vielleicht kann ich wissen erreichen
vielleicht nichts bisher habe ich das
nicht erreicht weil ich habe alle diese
argumente angeschaut und gesehen dass
sie im gleichgewicht sind aber wer weiß
bereiten dazu kommt kommt ein
überzeugendes argument wahrscheinlich
nicht aber ist die gleichzeitige frage
der wahrscheinlichkeit des wissens oder
der mögliche das wissens ist nichts eine
frage die ich beantworten kann ich meine
gedichte so dass er argumentieren also
erst offiziellen mindestens ist er immer
offen dafür dass auflagen gegenüber uns
ist immer bereit habe beiden seiten zu
argumentieren und seine eigene
überzeugung so enthalten aber allein in
dieser einhaltung erreicht der ruhe weil
er irgendwie
weil er irgendwie sozusagen aus dem
spiel ist also er muss keine ansichten
verteidigen gegen kritiker er muss nur
weiterhin suchen und warten sie seien
etwas überzeugendes acht haut was
natürlich nie passiert also grob sind
diese drei schulen also das wort man
sieht dass ethische ziele sehr zentral
in dieser in diesem zeitalter der fluss
piva alle drei schulen haben sehr betont
dass diese städtisches ziel von ruhe-
oder abwesenheit der unruhe erreichen
wollten und sie haben natürlich
versprochen dass nur sie das liefern
konnten
es ist eine interessante frage warum
diese schulen in dieser zeit so
erfolgreich waren manchmal sagt man dass
das war einst eine seite wo die
aristokraten keine politische macht
hatten und deswegen war es den heiligen
für die solche ansichten zu teilen die
impliziert haben dass sie nichts
politisch engagiert sein müssen um
glücklich zu werden sie müssen nur
akzeptieren die welt so wie sie ist oder
bei den apple kollegen sie müssen nur
sozusagen von der red zurücktreten und
sich mit fast nichts begnügen also ein
bisschen geld aber nicht sehr viele
freunde aber keine politische macht wie
er sagt das ist unnatürlich und einen
eine lehre wünschen ist dieses lehrers
sich wünschen dass statuen dann zu ehren
gebaut werden das ist lächerlich wenn
ich sowas haben will dann werde ich
wahrscheinlich noch mehr staaten nicht
noch mehr er da wenn ich nie zufrieden
hat diesem weg erwartet nicht nur unruhe
und unzufriedenheit wenn ich lerne dass
ich fast nichts brauche dann wenn ich
zufrieden das ist praktisch ein rezept
für politische untätigkeit und die
abitur waren auch politisch untätig
ok also grob eine skizze die der lasse
sie in diesem zeitalter
da könnt ihr natürlich sehr viel da der
mehrheit dazu sagen über mathe physik
psychologie und so weiter also nur
vielleicht nur kurz von der mathe physik
oder der die zusammen für sie sind diese
schulden das ist sehr bitter und traurig
sind naturalisten oder physikalischen
das heißt sie akzeptieren die nicht die
existenz von und körperlichen substanzen
die ja apple christina touristen die
story kann nicht aber ist was sie teilen
ist dass sie beide nur einen körper
denken also ist im körper der welt sogar
ist gott ein körper bei den store kann
und bei apple geräte integrieren und die
psychologie werden wir sowieso heute ein
bisschen näher besprechen aber grob
gesagt sind die beiden polizisten waren
die apple kassen sehr stark im
touristisch okay so viel zur einführung
und dann werde ich für die restliche
zeit natürlich ein bisschen über die
theorien der tiere riva tiere dieser
zeit sagen aber vielleicht mache ich
schon da pause sein ob jemand eine frage
hat über
wie soll der rund all das kommt noch
und jetzt sehr wichtig wie sie sehen
werden
doch es gibt eine serie wie die serie
besteht aus atomen wie auch bei dem
früheren atom essen vielleicht auf eine
sehr feine und runde und atome die durch
den restlichen körper so fließen können
die und historiker haben auch eine
körperliche sache die so was sie heiße
luft ist und gott ist auch nur feuer das
durch das ganze universum dann durch
drängt ist typisch historische theorie
dass zwei körper sich dann gänzlich
durchdringen können zb weinen kann
wasser durchdringen so dass in jedem
teil des wassers wein an anwesend ist
genau so ist gott in der ganzen welt
anwesend und meine seele in der in
meinem ganzen körper anwesend
vielleicht ist meine zelle sogar ein
teil des gottes aber die die eigentliche
idee ist dass die während die
kreationistische kamen zusammensetzungen
10 zum beispiel meine seele in meinem
körper aber das sind zwei atom ist ische
komplexe oder systeme die die
miteinander zusammen gewesen sind aber
nicht durchdringen sieht sich nicht
gegenseitig durchdringen bei den story
kann durchdringt die seele den körper
also überall wo der körper ist ist die
seele und umgekehrt auch bei tieren
übrigens also nicht relevant für uns die
frage
angefangen zu hören ist okay gut
diese hat aldi oder die happy korea und
historiker sind der ansicht genau wie er
das heute neben dass tiere keine keine
bindung zu besitzen
und hier ist das wort für vernunft
wichtig logos es kommt immer wieder vor
der geschichte für sie das vormoderne
philosophen oder auch moderne
philosophen wörter verwenden die schwer
zu übersetzen sind logos ist immer ein
lieblingsbeispiel um das zu zeigen wie
schwer es sein kann ein in diesem fall
altes wort in einem deutschen oder
englischen wort zu übersetzen
wir haben natürlich viele wörter in
unserer sprache die von logos abgeleitet
sind zum beispiel biologie also die
diese all diese lobby wörter kommen von
lucas das habe ich vielleicht sogar und
lukas heißt auch vernunft kann aber auch
sprache heißen kann auch bericht heißen
kann argument heißen grund also eine
begründung warum irgendwas der fall ist
das könnte ein logos sein oder logos
muss und so weiter und so fort
also alles was mit vernunft begründung
sprach resultat ist alles neu was
nebenbemerkung ich habe den eindruck
dass wir heutzutage dazu neigen zu sagen
sowieso was zu sagen wie dieses wort ist
wie vogue oder irgendwie problematisch
weil verschiedene begriffe unter logos
fallen und deswegen ist es auch
zweideutig zum also zum beispiel
verwenden sie das wort logos in einem
argument in unseres sich in zwei
verschiedene mit zwei verschiedenen
bedeutungen und deswegen ist das
argument irgendwie fehlerhaft aber da
würde ich da wäre ich vorsichtig und
würde immer sagen für die amtlichen ist
das ein wort und ein begriff und enthält
was für hundes verschiedene dezente
begriffe sind aber für sie sind diese
begriffe nicht getarnt und logos gerade
bei tieren ist ein paradebeispiel dafür
also tiere sind allgäu wasser logos
heißt unvernünftig oder besser von und
los also wenn umfeld weiter
ja was heißt das wir würden sagen jetzt
dass es irgendwie an zweiten es könnte
heißen entweder das tier keine von uns
haben oder dass sie nicht sprechen
ja also alle logos keine sprache oder
keine vernunft aber für die griechen ist
das nur ein hallo groß zu sein heißt
keine wohnung zu besitzen
beziehungsweise keine sprachkurse
besitzen weil und man sieht in einer
hand dieses wortes dass vernunft und
sprache zusammenkommen
sprache ist sogar das äußere zeichen der
inneren vernunft oder wir könnten sagen
es sowas wenn wir auch bei hat das ist
unsere sprache also dass der logos denke
wenn jemand spricht ist nur die der
körper doch nicht so sagen oder das
zeigen der inneren paar vernunft oder
kam dass in ihrem denken übrigens wörter
die mit denken zu tun haben sind auch
mit logos verwandt also logisch es daher
kann denken heißen oder überleben also
all diese ideen also dass das tier nicht
überlegen können dass sich denken können
dass sie nicht sprechen können die
kommen alle irgendwie zusammen unter
einem hut nämlich unter dieser
behauptung dass tiere aller gold sind
und denn die historiker dass es folglich
wenn die steuer verteidigen und das tier
der kataloge sind sagen sie ja die
sprechen nicht also offensichtlich haben
sie keinen keinen lagers sie machen zwar
geräusche also hunde bellen natürlich
das ist nicht der grund für sie haben
wir vielleicht oder wegen des bundes das
ist nicht sehr genommen wurde
wer will kann den hund als beispiel
nehmen
wenn ein hund bellt dass es keine
sprache und hat keine bedeutung
das ist nur wie die surfer sagen
ein schlag auf die luft also die die
luft wird integration gebracht oder so
also wird angepeilt
aber das ist nur ein geräusches was wie
ein stein was auf einen anderen
steinfeld das macht auch ein geräusch
und stößt die luft oder schlägt die luft
wie sie sagen würden habe an meine
bedeutung
deswegen das sind wir sogar bei zehn der
ärzte historiker der übrigens ein
zeitgenosse von hatte ließ war dass ich
übrigens interessant apple chur simon
der historiker
es gibt übrigens da muss man aufpassen
es gibt es gab auch den zähnen 10 euro
oder 10 der ein paar ein student und
unterstützer von paradis war sehen ein
derartiger und sie können ihn
wahrscheinlich als der der diese
argumente gebracht hat dass man sich zum
beispiel nicht bewegen kann weil man
musste die hälfte der strecke zu
erschaffen die um das zu machen muss man
die hälfte der hälfte also die fährt ein
viertel der strecke schaffen und dazu
machen die hälfte der hälfte und bis ins
unendliche und deswegen ist bewegung
möglich das kennen sie alle oder das ist
von einem zenon aber nicht von diesem
zählern
das war 10 der erreger das ist 10 10 und
der historiker oder zehnten von kittel
der sap gründer von saudis muss ist fast
gleichzeitig mit alles dort riss epikur
und kieron der erste skeptiker ist
wirklich faszinierend als bass als ob
die regierung gedacht hat wir brauchen
mehr philosophische schulen wir stiften
das anrecht
aber das ist nur zufall natürlich aber
es ist interessant dass wir all diese
philosophen was gleichzeitig haben
auf jeden fall sagt sie nun eben das
dass tiere keine nichts keine bedeutsame
sprache haben
späte 1 1 auch früher aber dann etwas
später historiker dirk nies von babylon
sagte dass tiere eine stimme haben vorne
aber keine sprache und ähnliches sind
wir auch bei solchen ist das natürlich
geräusche machen können aber keine
bedeutsame geräusche und der ansprache
ist bedeutsam sind das ist natürlich
bedeutsame wird soll es also ein 3 1 im
1 stimme ist nicht gleich sprache weil
man nicht nach johannes stimme haben
keine ohne etwas zu sagen ja zum
beispiel ein hund der welt
vielleicht könnten wir kurz nachdenken
ab ob das plausibel ist weil es nicht
unwichtiges wie sie sein werden ob das
stimmt oder nicht wie wenn auch nächste
woche in das profil des diese diese
theorie angreift wieso würden würde man
sagen dass tiere keine sprache besitzen
das wirkt ein bisschen seltsam weil man
zum beispiel meine katze papa macht sehr
deutlich wenn sie essen will unter
anderem mit ihrer stimme
sie ist übrigens eine art von katze die
sehr gesprächig ist
sie ist halb es gibt eine tasse heißen
das heißt maine coon ist ein sehr schick
ja das ist nur halb menschen also diese
relativ groß aber nicht so lächerlich
weil rechnungen können da sie die
aktiven können sind wirklich monster und
wir haben auch wenn man etwas nervös
also wird das geholt haben
weil wir haben sie als kätzchen bekommen
und dann haben wir genug ist ein
erwachsenes männchen aus
habe sie ist etwas kleiner geblieben
gott sei dank ist auch weiblich auf
jeden fall
diese art von katze ist sehr gesprächig
also die leute würden sagen nein mit
gespräch sie haben keine sprache sind
nur geständig oder was auch immer
aber sie ist dauernd und man hat sehr
sehr stark den eindruck dass sie
irgendwas ausdrücken welt zb um viertel
nach 16 uhr
jeden tag kommt sie und behauptet dass
es schon 17 uhr ist
deshalb sehen wir wieder ins essenszeit
pressen zeit ist und versucht uns sehr
haus zu krieg zu sagen dass es schon
seit es für diese klassen dann sagen wir
nein und wir reden mit ihr also ob wir
mit ihr austauschen und das machen wir
auch natürlich es gibt auch jetzt müssen
wir das machen gibt die bezeichnung
sprache kommunizieren können
es ist sehr schwer die solche these dann
das zu halten wenn man das sieht aber
man ist also die story co hätten das
nicht wissen können aber sie hätten
schon wissen können dass tiere
irgendwelche geräusche haben um
irgendwas auszudrücken ja das ist
irgendwie offensichtlich und was die
historiker sagen würden ist dass diese
geräusche vielleicht etwas ausdrücken
aber keine bedeutung haben was es
bedeutet bedeutung ist warum die sorge
würden seien das ist eine eine
historische bedeutung das heißt die
behaupten nicht dass irgendwas der fall
sei wurde dass irgendein satz war ist es
gibt einen paradieses wort laptop
von dem werk sagen ein laptop ist also
buchstabe das gesagte oder besser das
sagt bade das was man sagen kann und
laptop oder letta letta sind die die
diejenige sachen die man mit sprache
ausdrücken kann oder bedeuten kann
das heißt sagen die wahr sind oder nicht
und was die historiker deswegen sagen
würden ist das wenn ich den eindruck
habe dass papa behaupten würde dass es
jetzt schon 17 uhr ist das wäre ein
lektor sie jetzt 17 uhr oder ist es
jetzt zeit fürs lassen sie würden sagen
nein sie hat nur hunger und äußert sich
weil sie hunger hat das ist was anderes
das ist nur automatismus dass mit dass
mehr wie gestoßen
gegen einen stein eine stein mit meinen
zeh und sage oder wenn ich deutsch werde
würde ich sagen das hat mich übrigens
immer fasziniert nebenbemerkung
wir sagen sie sagen aber es ist
unglaublich wie die firma die deutsche
kinder anfangen dieses christliches
geräusch zu machen dass kein
vernünftiger mensch sagen würde
aber wo kommt dieses jahr her dass heißt
das heißt was auch das ist noch weiter
weg vielleicht werden wir heute nicht
einig ist händler auf jeden fall wenn
man wenn man seeanstoss und sollte man
sagt dann dass das hat auch keine
bedeutung das ist nicht die äußeren die
haben ein sehr jetzt angestoßen hat das
hat er getan wenn ich das haus
regelmäßig sagen was ist passiert
also ich werde das man kennt sagt
fragment kennt was ist passiert
ich habe mein zeh angestoßen das hat
wehgetan okay jetzt sind wir bei sprache
das bedeutet eine bedeutung dass es eine
äußerung die eine wahrheit ausdrucken
will oder eine gewollte wahrheit
natürlich können äußerungen auch falsch
sein
das heißt man drückt einen laptop aus
während ein tier das nicht machen kann
ein tier kann nur ihre stimme einsetzen
um irgendwas auszudrücken was unter der
ebene der wahrheit fällt zum beispiel
schmerz oder hunger okay so ein hund
kann man kann ein tier quellen wir
leider wird man kann ein tier quellen
das wird auch geräusche machen wir es
noch mal keine behauptung ist nur ein
eine initiative reaktion nachdem soll
kann
sie brachen in diesem konzept nicht nur
das was über laute spüren also nächsten
sturm guter punkt und das ist mit dem
verband was ich gerade sagen wollte
wobei da würde ich auch sagen
also wird was zuerst vielleicht ein feld
ist schöpft man bei halberstadt lesen
ist haben wir die behauptung dass wir
unsere gedanken haben und dazu äußern
setzen wir ein zeichen davon dass es
sprache also war der schwache und dann
heißt zeichen davon benutzen der schrift
also wir haben sozusagen drei schritte
denken sprechen schreiben und ich weiß
nicht ob er etwas über zeichensprache
sagt vielleicht nicht aber er würde
sagen es bei zeichensprache ist ich weiß
nicht also er könnte entweder sagen
zeichen schade ist wie geräusche und die
gedanken auszudrücken oder geschäft und
normale sprache aus würden
wahrscheinlich würde der erste sagen das
erste sagen müssen weil sie nur eine
alternative art gedanken auszudrücken
dann sind wir dritter werden
die wichtigsten beispiele für die
natürliche benutzer des bundes als 800
die kommunizierte konzepte es kommt ein
eindringling auf das grundstück der und
der oder
ja genau und was wir sehr oft in dieser
in dieser ganzen serie von vorlesungen
sehen werden ist dass es kontroverse was
genau tiere begreifen können und wie sie
darauf reagieren können
und irgendwie am gut dass wir mit all
diesen dienstag anfangen weil sie sehr
bescheidene erwartungen von tieren haben
also viel historiker ist es der fall
dass man einen hund scheint irgendetwas
zu machen was so was impliziert also
dass der hund einen lektor hast wird das
ist nie der fall also der wenn ein
einbrecher reinkommt und der hund bellt
das ist nur so etwas wie angst oder wut
oder irgendwas das können sie spüren
und die können instinktiv daraus
reagieren unter anderem dadurch dass die
beiden aber sie können keine äußerungen
machen zum beispiel und was zu sagen
dass ein einbrecher da ist aber das
bleibt werden wir das besser verstehen
nachdem nicht mehr über die psychologie
gesagt habe das ist das kommt noch
aber eigentlich erweise sich der kritik
an kamen die skeptiker sagt dass in
türkis vorrang und sagt dass diese
argumente nicht überzeugenden sind im
grunde genommen was die historiker und
die apple korea ist hier sagen wollten
nämlich dass die tiere keine sprache
haben ist hat als basis die tatsache
dass wir in den in der stimme oder den
geräuschen der tieren keine bedeutung
erkennen
bis auf zb hunger schmerz und so weiter
also wir können wir können aus diesen
geräuschen keine historische bedeutung
erschießen
aber das kommt auch oft bei menschen
wenn wir nach china fahren oder die
würde sagen wenn wir bei den skizzieren
sind oder was auch immer
wenn wir bei einem volk sind vielleicht
wahrscheinlich gibt es mindestens eine
person die die chinesisch kann kann hier
jemand chinesisch das ist ein bisschen
einfach ein bisschen chinesisches 10
chinesischen ja okay also für holen
müssen wir müssen uns also das auf
chinesisch lernen wenn wir nach china
fahren wir hin viele geräusche in der
straße und verstehen gar nichts
aber wir können wir dürften nicht daraus
schließen dass chinesen keine vernunft
besitzen und auch dort wird dürften
somit das erschließen dass die geräusche
keine sprache sind natürlich ist das
sprache ist nur schwierig die wir nicht
verstehen
vielleicht ist es bei tieren ähnlich das
ist ein argument führte gegen gibt dann
sagt er deswegen habe gesagt ihre frage
ist relevant er sagt es gibt auch
menschen die keine geräusche machen
können oder die keine sprache vor sie
gehen können aber sie haben auch
trotzdem intern am see vernunft also
beiden seiten das sozusagen ist diese
schlussfolgerung falsch ist die
abwesenheit der bedeutsamen sprache
heißt nicht dass der luft abwesend ist
und die anwesenheit von geräuschen die
wir nicht verstehen können heißt auch
nicht dass keine sprache und deswegen
keine vernunft anwesen ist und das kommt
bei 6 ziemlich schnell dass das geht
ziemlich schnell verweise das sagt er
natürlich nur als widerlegung des tores
university oder der solchen behauptung
hier aber die wir letzte woche senden
wird das thematisiert man ausführlich
von profis behandelt
aber es ist wirklich interessant es ist
eine hauptfrage in der nächsten sitzung
für uns ob tiere sprache besitzen und
ländern was das heissen würde und wie
sie sein werden
der hatte profitierte doch schwache
haben und selbst wenn sie keine sparte
hätten oder keine schwache haben die wir
verstehen können heißt es nicht dass sie
keine vernunft besetzen
okay aber bisher in mainz ist
wahrscheinlich von den surfern nicht so
beeindruckt weil sie nur bisher hatte
ich nur diese relativ die sie diese
relativ im plausible theorie über die
sprache erwähnt aber was sie im
allgemeinen sortiert psychologie zu
sagen haben ist sehr interessant
unter anderem weil es eine interessante
psychologische theorie auch über
menschen darstellt ok also hier die
psychologische tiere als 70 leute
theorie über tiere und auch menschen bei
den storage system wenn ich sage
psychologische theorie was sich in der
ersten linie damit meine ist handlungs
theorie so was sie hier erklären wollen
ist die handlung entsteht und auch die
überzeugung entsteht ist wie sie sein
werden ist das ähnlich überzeugung ohne
handlung ist eigentlich nur ist genau
wie eine behandlung entstehen würde ist
nur dass die handlung keine
impliziert zum beispiel wenn ich
überzeugt denn das 1 0 1 gleich zwei ist
das impliziert keine handlung
normalerweise und die theoretisch hat so
aus
okay da bin ich ja das ist heute nicht
mein geburtstag
falls sie wissen neunzehnter akkus
geschenke bekommen aber er ist natürlich
weihnachten also wenn sie etwas für mich
schon ausgesucht haben dann weihnachten
kommt zuerst aber nehmen wir an ist mein
geburtstag nehmen wir an auch dass ich
nur vier jahre alt bin
kerzen also ich sehe einen kuchen und
ich habe funktionierende eine
funktionierende wahrnehmungsfähigkeit
also ich der ein abbild des guten saison
in meinen augen auf oder in meiner sms
barnim und genau wie das funktioniert
ist uns mit so wichtig ist aber
interessant weil zum beispiel die apple
behaupten das weil alles als atom
besteht muss ja kein wie wahrnehmung
funktioniert
würden sie sagen dass das sehr dünne
schichten von atomen die essener dollar
also bilder werden von allen körpern zu
sagen abgeworfen und berühren unsere
sinnesorgane und bewegung setzen die
sinnesorgane in bewegung und dann durch
die seele erreicht uns ein ein eindruck
von dem was wir sehen also die erkennen
dass alles durch die rein körperliche
beziehungen und ähnlich bei den soll
kann aber nicht mit nicht natürlich
nicht mit atomen
es gibt eine
körperliche beziehungen und verbindung
zwischen dem kuchen und meiner seele und
wenn diese wenn die meine wahrnehmung
den eindruck bekommt das ein kuchen da
auf dem tisch steht habe ich eine
fantasie von irgendwas s bahn s bahn
lange überlegt wie ich fantasiere auf
deutsch übersetzen soll und ich bin zum
ergebnis gekommen dass man das als
anscheinend übersetzen soll mit hilfe
meiner familie
also anscheinend weil das wort phantasie
kommt von dem werk für erscheinen oder
scheinen zum beispiel wenn man das sieht
man im katholischen dialog und manchmal
wenn das opfer dies fragt ist erst der
fall dass xy
dann sagt der alt der andere feine teil
das heißt es scheint so wurde
anscheinend also einen anschein ist die
der wenn man den eindruck hat dass
irgendwas der fall lässt
und ich habe vorher gesagt dass hier der
einsatz ist oder die anschein ist der
anschein ist dass ich was essbar ist bei
mir sehr aber es ist vielleicht zu
schwach was ich anhabe ist den eindruck
dass hier irgendwas liegt was ich essen
soll oder was gut ist inszeniert von
magna ist und deswegen sollte ich das
essen und das und das kann einen so
genannten anstoß produzieren
das gebäude ist also eine tendenz das
ding zu greifen oder nach sie schweben
oder anzustreben
und dass das deshalb würde eigentlich
nur heißen dass ich so sagen in bewegung
gesetzt werde
in richtung zu handen dass ich in diesem
fall den kuchen esse okay aber bisher
passiert nichts weil ich als mensch
immer noch in der lage bin diesen anstoß
zu widerstand gegen den anstoß an stolz
zu leisten oder sozusagen den anstoß zu
abzuwerfen oder nicht zu akzeptieren
erfreulich dann handeln muss ich wie die
historiker sagen würden zustimmen
und diese zustimmung hat als folge eine
handlung nämlich ich gehe zum tisch und
schneide den kuchen unternehmen ein
stück raus und es den restlichen kunden
also hier haben wir sozusagen ein kreis
wo der kuchen mich beeinflusst mich
sozusagen in bewegung setzt aber nur
dadurch dass ich der fantasie zu der
fantasie zustimme also ich musste haben
diesen anschein sozusagen akzeptieren
dass das was vorher steht der krieg gut
zu essen ist warum ich den kuchen hessen
gerne essen würde es laut klar
wie würde es ausschauen wenn ich den
coolen nicht essen würde vielleicht weiß
ich dass ich in einem museum denn wo
viele objekte so umlegen die aus wachs
sind wie gehen ein zimmer und sehe einen
kuchen auf den tisch ist sehr
realistisch scheint genauso aus wie ein
leckerer kuchen
ich würde aber trotzdem den kuchen nicht
essen war echte zu der so der fantasie
nicht zustimmen würde
also ich hab ich habe schon die den
anschein dass das hier leckere kuchen
ist stimme nicht zu weil meine von uns
wahrscheinlich aus bachs weil du in
diesem sinn ist oder auch am fleck bin
ich schon doch überzeugt dass das buch
habe ich weiß ist es nicht mein
geburtstag es ist der geburtstag meiner
erfahrung
sie ist noch nie zu hause und deswegen
so tief scheine den quoten noch nie
dessen also ich warte lieber würde er
das heißt es könnte bild ex liege
gründen haben den kurven nicht zu essen
und die würden dann verhindern nicht
dass ich den eindruck habe dass der
kuchen dass ein kuchen da ist und dass
er es wahr ist
ich würde ihn nur das würde nur heißen
dass ich meine zustimmung an den
anschein nicht verleihen und das war für
die historiker sehr sehr wichtig denn
sie der ansicht waren dass es möglich
ist für perfekte philosophen immer alle
falschen überzeugungen zu vermeiden
also das heißt der perfekte philosophie
einfelder gainey und das kann könnten
das klar kann ein philosoph nur dadurch
vermeiden dass er seine zustimmung
enthält denn er weiß dass die dass die
anschein
die ihn erreicht haben nicht ausreichend
sind um ihn zu überzeugen
sie besprechen beispiele wie rahden
jemand sagt sagt mir ein zeigt mir ein
ei dann hält es hinter seinem rücken
dann seid ihr noch ein heim sagt ist das
das gleiche objekt ein fehler so würde
sagen vielleicht aber ich weiß nicht
also es scheint so aber ich behalte
meine zustimmung weil ich nicht weiß man
man sieht man kann sie ja die ganze
geschichte es hernach wie gesagt auch
für überzeugungen die nächste handlungen
zu tun haben also das reine es technisch
dann würde ich einen anschein haben die
ich die mich dazu bringt irgendwas zu
glauben aber ich könnte meine
überzeugung immer zurückhaltend oder
enthalten
vielleicht war sie also ich bin noch
nicht überzeugt bin nur überzeugt wenn
ich wirklich ausreichende gründe haben
habe deswegen habe ich nur überzeugungen
wo ich wirklich sicherte
wenn ich ein perfekter verlosung gut
okay so schaut es bei menschen aus wie
schaut es bei tieren aus
genauso aber ohne zustimmung bei dem
holz
[Musik]
haben wir halt das alles dasselbe nur
dass der hund nicht vermeiden kann
vielleicht würden würden wir dazu neigen
es seien darin kann nicht vermeiden ist
eine zustimmung zu geben
was wisst was die server das sagen er
ist dass sie nie zustande
die reagieren nur also dieser schritt
kommt bei den tieren gar nicht vor weil
das der stadt ist wo vernunft eingreift
kann dieses verfahren stoppen sagen
stopp ich bin nicht überzeugt
denn die fern und doch überzeugt ist
dann lasst sie das verfahren laufen
es stimmt zu der zudem anschein zu und
sagt okay dann essen wir das übrigens
die diesjährige würden auch sagen dass
ein philosoph ein perfekter falles auf
manchmal vielleicht handeln würde auch
uns sicher zu sein
aber seid dann würde nichts mit
überzeugung handeln würde sondern nur
sagen okay vielleicht es scheint so zu
sein dass es wäre vernünftig soll so
handeln obwohl ich nicht sicher bin also
ich würde kein sozusagen ohne
überzeugung handeln
das wäre in einer das wird gleich werde
warnt wenn ich die skeptiker kurz
gesperrt
infizierte überlegung nein nein gar
nicht
jetzt kommt es sehr davon abhängen wie
also was zum beispiel die gewohnheiten
und präferenzen des menschen sind also
ich zb wenn sie zum beispiel keinen
kuchen markt mögen dann wird der kuchen
ob sie mit services wie er leider hat
mich wird das alles könnte völlig
verschieden sein
aber das tut uhr ist immer das gleiche
also endlich in ihrem fall weil sie
keinen kuchen mögen im dann ja dann
würden sie es würden sie zum beispiel
einen anschein haben dass ein kuchen auf
dem tisch steht und das könntest du eine
überzeugung führen die sie auch stoppen
könnte könnten aber nichts nicht zu dem
anstoß und mögliche handlung führen weil
sie haben sowieso keinen anschein dass
das was genießbare selbst ok also ich
hab gesagt dass das ist alles genau so
wie bei tieren wie bei uns aber ist dass
das ist nicht ganz richtig weil für die
historiker vernunft so seien die ganze
säle und psychologie durch drängt und
das würde bedeuten dass wir
interpretieren so sagen die welt mit
phantasie an scheine die schon
professionell gebaut sondern hier sind
wir zurück zu die lätta also dass wir
für uns die wir legen die welt so aus so
sein dass alles sprachlich oder implizit
sprachlich beschrieben wird und wir
sehen den kuchen als ein einen s-bahn-
kuchen oder anders gesagt wenn wir den
kuchen sehen dann in luynes geselle
kommt so was vor wie auch hier ist ein
essbarer kuchen und
vielleicht sollte ich ihn hassen soll
ich ihn essen oder misshandlung ja wenn
bei tiere nicht vorkommt was sprachlich
strukturiert ist sie haben sozusagen
keine positionen würden wir sagen dieser
gewinn sagen die arbeiten mit keinem
nackter also die die können jetzt sagen
und deswegen können sie auch nichts
denken was mit dem sagbaren zu tun hat
also es gibt keine äußerungen sogar
impliziten äusserungen in derselben des
bundes zum beispiel das kommt nur beim
menschen vor
und die namens zum ernsten band davon so
überzeugt dass sie gegenbeispiele
irgendwie anders interpretieren mussten
und jetzt kommen wir zu dem hund das ist
dann würde mich denn hund gewählt habe
weil das heutige bild chris pine der
wahrscheinlich interessanteste figur ist
historiker der viele super logik und
technologie bbt geschrieben hat die post
hat folgendes beispiel betrachtet eine
holzhalle eine beute nach kommt zu einer
kreuzung mit drei wege
also der hand steht hier an der kreuzung
und muss sich entscheiden ob er den weg
a b oder c wählen soll
und der hund schnüffelt bei b k league
nichts sich die beute nicht nur bei
weg.de liegt die beute nichts und ohne
ist so schnüffeln läuft es derzeit
entlang
angeblich weil aber ist das nicht
beobachten dass wir das machen ja also
nehmen wir an ein hund hat das gemacht
okay was heißt dass das hat anscheinend
hat der hund eines it mit nicht mal das
sondern ein regelwerk das
philosophisches argument nicht wieder
soziologisches argument verwendet oder
bei oder sei nicht nicht
deswegen sehe drei prämisse anschluss
offensichtlich eine eine verwendung von
vernunft und christoffers hat das alles
zugegeben das phänomen zu geben aber
gesagt dass das nur der name denken dass
dynamo heißt potenziell oder der
potenzial i tät nach oder dass der
möglichkeit nach es heißt habe
vielleicht implizit denken aber nicht
wirklich denken der potenziale t könnt
ihr vielleicht heißt es nur nicht
wirklich nicht ganz wirklich oder als ob
das ist sozusagen im schein von und das
ist nur instinkt oder intuition
vielleicht aber der hund hat das alles
gemacht ohne ohne denken und zu denken
und auch ohne denken zu können
ich muss sagen als dass da also für mich
ist das ziemlich überzeugend meine
verwendet nur das motto name also der
möglichkeit nach nur um das problem
sozusagen vom tisch zu wischen also ich
denke dass das wird ist so solche
phänomene sind für die historiker sehr
schwer zu erklären und sie müssen nur
darauf bestehen ja immer kann mehr mit
instinkt machen als man vielleicht meine
würde aber für sie grund ist es
grundlegend dass wir alles mit vernunft
machen tiere gar nichts mit 5 und wir
sind sehr froh es scheint dass wir mit
den tieren sehr viel gemeinsam haben wir
in der tat sehr gut mit den tieren
gemeinsam weil wir bei jeder handlung
bei jeder reaktion auf der welt bei
jeder entstehung eine überzeugung
vernunft einsetzen weil wir immer
zustimmen müssen und wir müssen
zustimmen zu irgendwas was so ein kropf
sitzen gebaut ist also diese panthers
haben schon implizit komplett
oppositionelle vor
die sind alle implizit zusagen für ein
tier das gar nicht der fall ist und hier
ist alles automatisch einfach der com
gegen wirkung passen die einstein oder
sowas
interessant übrigens überlegen wie die
skeptiker darauf wie ihr geld haben und
dass das wäre ein langes thema zu
besprechen die die statistiker mit
überzeugungen umgegangen sind wie ich
vorher gesagt habe dass praktiker die
eigenen bereit waren zu behaupten dass
sie von nichts überzeugt sind
aber um das problem zu vermeiden dass
man dann sagen müsste ich bin überzeugt
dass keine überzeugung richtig ist dass
offensichtlich paradox ist haben die
sprecher der skeptiker 56 das gesagt ich
bin immer hoffen also ich bin nicht
überzeugt aber so weit wie werde ich ihm
werde ich irgendwann von irgendwas
überzeugt bisher sei nicht geschehen
aber so oder so lebt der skeptiker ohne
überzeugung entsteht die frage wie macht
das charakter gleich irgendetwas also
das beispiel was sie immer
bringen ist sehr römisch ich habe die
ich bin ich habe den eindruck dass sich
baden muss deswegen gehe ich so die
bilder
okay man die geburt der enkel so die
bäder wir sehen dass september auch so
die bäder gehen wieso machen sie das
wenn sie keine überzeugung haben also
ist sie könnten genauso gut senken
ich möchte ich möchte baden deswegen
soll ich mich erschießen oder ich möchte
fahren deswegen soll ich hier einfach
sitzen bleiben weil sie keine
überzeugungen halten und die skeptiker
sagen das stimmt wir haben keine
überzeugungen wir reagieren nur darauf
wie alles scheint und gehen einfach mit
so sagen also wir lassen uns von der
welt beeinflusst sein und reagieren ganz
natürlich darauf ohne überzeugungen zu
haben und jeder weise haben die story
genau die waffen in die hände der steuer
geliefert was die historiker brauchen
weil die sorge wird nur sagen ja wir
machen das genauso wie ihr nur um eine
zustimmung
also wir nicht dass wir zustimmen
enthalten
wir stimmen auch nicht zu dass das
falsch ist wir zustimmen einfach gar
nicht zu wir lassen diesen schritt
auszusagen behandeln ohne zuzustimmen
die story gewinnen sagen das ist
unmöglich allein die tatsache dass er
gehandelt hat zeigt dass er zugestimmt
hat die story die skater können sagen
nein das ist genau wie bei tieren
wir lassen uns zu lassen die welt uns
einfach in bewegung setzen
der gern natürlich darauf kommen an bei
den bildern
kein problem also man könnte sagen die
skeptiker leben was die tiere und
historiker und die während des wegen des
streits zwischen den story kann und den
skeptikern in diesem fall ob das möglich
ist es
möglich für ein mensch der einen mensch
zu handeln ohne zustimmen also ohne
überzeugt zu sein und die historiker
sagen nein es gab da sagen ja also macht
hier sieht man dass die tiere fast
vorbild für die skeptiker werden während
für die menschen und jede so weit
auseinander dass es unmöglich ist für
ein mensch bei jedem weil sogar eine
einzelne handlung sich wie ein tier zu
benennen beim du musst jedes mal die von
amt einsetzen und zustimmen
und da drin besteht deine freiheit als
mensch halt deine freiheit ist ganz
bestimmt genau darin dass du entweder
zustimmen kannst oder deine zu stimmen
enthalten kannst und diese war es für
sie das zu sagen das moment der freiheit
in der handlung also für sie wurden sie
würden sagen dass die skeptiker
behaupten dass sie handeln können kunis
uhr entscheiden und es ist zu
entscheiden und das ist natürlich
unmöglich nein natürlich stimmen sie zu
sie bilden sich nur ein dass sie die
zustimmen
und dass die tiere sie dass sie wie
tiere handeln könnten
aber das ist nur möglich weil wir eben
gerade weil die skeptiker auf menschen
sind und nur mit volldampf agieren
können
dabei fragen über zu gefolgt hätte schon
seite kommen
jetzt ist das interessante frage an wie
wir später sehen werden über werden sehr
lang in der geschichte die diese
behauptung sein dass tiere einfach
automatisch auf also hingehen was ihnen
gutscheins und dass die keine salz
beherrschung besitzen das im mittelalter
auf und in der firma der eine also um
dieses phänomen zu erklären müsste man
eigentlich sagen dass sie trainieren des
hundes es dazu der den hund dazu
gebracht hat dass er den kuchen als
etwas schmerzliches empfindet nicht
alles was kostet es
also er verbindet schmerz mit dem
schlagen denn das er vorher erlebt hat
und deswegen hat er am anfang einen hand
ein dass des albums wert ist zu müssen
sie das erkenntnis nicht sehr
überzeugend war das werde die erklären
oder müsste die erklärung sein
folge traf ich halbtot die aktiven die
erzgehalte die wieder auf trab gebracht
nur die stimmen der wand zu brechen
konnte ich mir gar nicht kann dies von
sich geben aber sich perfekt als sie
meinen dass die historiker sagen dass
tiere keine sprache besitzen können aber
irgendwas mit tanja sie können
kommunizieren können vielleicht auch
sagen aber es sieht arbeiten nur sind
wichtig für sie dass sie keine
professionelle inhalt kommunizieren
können sie können nur sozusagen einfache
gefühle mitteilen zum beispiel ich
hunger vielleicht wieder mal das nur
weil ich will dass also die diese idee
dass man sachverhalte dann zu sagen
infor auge hat und kommuniziert oder
zustimmt oder web haben will das alles
bei den storage ausgeschlossen für tiere
ja genau also wir für sie wir sagen als
menschen haben wir diese diese tendenz
tiere zu kontrollieren und deswegen
legen wir das so aus als ob sie
professionell denken ist aber nicht
erfragen
[Musik]
aber das glaube ich sollte würden sagen
das perfekt für uns weil er halt der
hund mit entweder fremder bekannter das
ist so da hört es egal
die garage fährt mit auto bild nicht
kein auto kommt dann welt aber nein das
ist veränderten auto nicht gebaut ist
das kann man sich ja dieses nicht denken
das ist ja reaktion
übrigens haben dieses wort anstoß da
könnte man auch im puls gehabt hätte so
gar kein post
natürlich habe ich mir gesagt ist
erreicht haben wollte nur sagen was sie
behaupten
ok jetzt ist
ja genau
ja die im kreis würden aussagen dass man
sich trainieren was und sich so wie ein
tier zeit hier sogar zu verhalten also
dieses die diese idee dass man
überzeugungen halten soll und nur
handeln ohne zustimmung
das ist für sie ist nicht so sein sie
würden nicht wahrhaben dass das immer
beim menschen vorkommen nur bei den
skeptikern und das müssen sie auch gibt
sogar also diese diese übung nichts zu
akzeptieren was nicht sicher ist aber
das müssen sie die story kann auch sagen
weil er gesagt der perfekte film so
handels manchmal ohne überzeugt zu sein
gerade wenn er nicht sicher ist oder
weiß dass er nicht sicher sein kann
ok so kritische seite die also erstens
muss man sagen dass die diese
philosophen haben viel über tiere in der
etliche zusagen was nicht sehr groß zu
gibt es zusagen sind also erstens ist es
für sie noch mal grundlegend das tier
keine vernunft besitzen
zum beispiel sagt anacker in seinen
briefen dass alle unsere gute
eigenschaften teilen zum beispiel wir
können stark seien tiere auch wir können
gut wahrnehmen tiere auch wir können
schön sein tiere auch das einzige was
wir haben was sie nicht haben ist
vernunft und der stängel liegt ist es in
der vernunft dass unsere möglichkeit
glückseligkeit als menschen liegt genau
wie beiersdorf ist wir müssen das nutzen
was uns eigen ist und das einzige was
uns eigenes ist vernunft also diese
aristotelischen überlegung für den wir
auch bei seiner kann zum beispiel und
die tatsache dass tiere keine vernunft
besitzen
heißt das sie keine ethische werk vor
uns haben
das heißt bei dem song kann und auch bei
den bis dato gehören also sagen wir sind
nicht sicher auf dem herd prozent oder
nichts also ich konzentriere mich auf
die erste kurve korea an manchmal kommt
haben wir die idee dass tiere haben
eigentlich nur da sind hat der welt da
sind weil gott durch seine göttliche
vorsehung es sichern wollte dass wir
tiere als mitteln für unsere zwecke
hernehmen können zb wir das bei cicero
gesagt dass schafe nur existieren damit
wir baumwolle haben oder dass der nur
existieren damit wir auf jagd gehen
können also in der mensch ist sozusagen
im mittelpunkt des geschehens in den
ganzen universum und alles alle andere
tierarten sind nur da als wir werkzeuge
für uns bei christos angeblich gab es
sogar die behauptung dass die seele des
schweins an so gestaltet ist dass das
fleisch des schweines salzig wird damit
der schweiz gut schmeckt
also ist dass die die serie und
körperliche bau eines schweins ist alles
von gott durchdacht damit wir die
schweine hessen können und sie lag offen
also das ist alles ziemlich also wir
sind sehr sehr weit weg von vegetarismus
das ist nicht nur dass wir die tiere
essen dürfen sondern dass die tiere
wirklich nur existieren damit wir sie
essen
maike tier hat mindestens und das ist
irgendwie ironisch weil ein
grundlegendes prinzip in der eltec in
der hanseatic genauso viel für tiere
relevantes wie für menschen und dieses
prinzip ist hieß es
es heißt so was die einheit kommt von
dem wort post großes haus also das ist
das was für uns geeignet ist oder
geeignet und für die für alle hessischen
schulen vielleicht nicht für die skater
gabe für die dogmatische schön war es
grundlegend zu sagen dass wir wird sogar
bei neugeborenen babys sehen wir dass
menschen bewusst sind von dem was ihnen
eigene nest oder geeignet ist also je
sogar babys haben eine natürliche
natürlich streben an nachdem den sachen
die für sie gut sind oder natürlich
geeignet sind zum beispiel die mit der
mutter und die sehr interessante ist ein
philosoph namens hajduk designs der
uecker der verschiedene interessante
sachen überall cases gesagt hat zum
beispiel dass der das und das sagt
übrigens über tiere nicht nur menschen
dass alle lebewesen sich selbst
wahrnehmen können und wissen wie sie
ihre glieder einsetzen sollen zum
beispiel tiere wissen von der natur aus
wie sie ihre krallen einst als waffen
einsetzten können oder welche arten von
pflanzen für sie geeignet ist und so
weiter und so fort das kann man alles
durch eine natürlich ein natürliches
gefühl oder ein natürliches talent zu
sein
das identifizieren und was ist also was
geeignet ist und die für die story und
auch für die apple korea ist es wirklich
wichtig nur das recht haben zu wollen
das problem also probleme hinten im
leben kommen fast immer vor wenn man
irgendein wunsch entwickelt irgendetwas
zu haben was natürlich nicht geeignet
ist super
sie erinnern sich daran ich habe gesagt
dass die apple-geräte kohl selbst hat
leute geschimpft weil sie statuen und
erde haben wollte wollten
und wenn er das sagt er dass das ist
eine art von lust was unnatürlich ist
wenn du wissen willst was natürlich ist
schau tiere und neugeborene babys an
sie wollen nur einfache normale lust
genießen und das sollten wir auch also
die einfachste das einfachste ersten
kein luxus nur ganz einfach sagen genau
wie tiere und menschen wollen die noch
nicht von der gesellschaft durcheinander
gebracht und verdorben sind und kam halb
die sagt was alles was ich ihnen vorlebt
vorlesen wollte weil ich zu das so schön
findet übrigens die an diese auszüge von
krisen anderes zeug finden sie auch in
einer lesung die auf alles zu finden ist
sogar auf deutsch deutsche übersetzung
haben
das ist das hier ist eine passage wo
hajo gies und unser ethische entwicklung
so beschreibt dass das eine auszeichnung
und der gefühle für das geeignete wahl
bettet so hajo gies von stoffers
berichtet das ist übrigens § 57 g in der
in dem in der datei die sie auf alle
surfen
jeder von uns ist jetzt sozusagen von
vielen kreisen ganz umgebung geben wovon
die heime kleiner und die anderen größer
sind die letzten umschließen und die
ersten umschlossen entsprechen ihren
unterschiedlichen und ungleichen
beziehungen zueinander denn der erste
und hengste kreis ist der den jemand wie
um ein zentrum herum gezogen hat seinen
eigenen verstand
dieser kreis schließt den körper und
alles was uns jetzt des körpers wenn
hinzu kommen wird denn es ist beinahe
der kleinste kreis unna berührt fast das
zentrum also in der mitte dann mein
eigener körper das ist der erste kreis
von da ist der zweite kreis ist zwar
weiter vom zentrum weg herum schließt
aber den ersten haben die eltern die
geschwister die frau und die kinder
ihren platz als nächstes kommt der
dritte kreis der die onkeln und tanten
umfasst die größte und großmütter die
nerven nicht in aufwertung und cousinen
der kreis danach bezieht die übrigen
verwandten ein
der nächste clijsters die bewohner der
ortsgemeinde der nächste die mitglieder
des volksstammes der nächste die bürger
der stadt und so weiter wird weiß der
leute aus den nachbarstädten dann der
mit den nachbarländern
der äußerste im größte kreis der alle
diese kreise umfasst ist der des ganzen
menschengeschlechts nachdem man sich
hier über also einen überblick
verschafft hat stellt sich für den ko
template temperierten man bei der
passenden behandlung jede gruppe die
aufgabe die kreise irgendwie zum zentrum
zusammen zu ziehen und mit eifer stets
die leute aus den anschließenden kreisen
in die umschlossenen zu versetzen also
die idee ist ich als also meine
verstandes der mittelpunkt und dann mein
körper meine enge familie andere
verwandte dann mit bewohnern meiner
stadt usw
das allen menschen der welt und ethische
entwicklung und fortschritt ist wenn ich
die
die leute die weiter wachsen zusammen so
betrachte er als ob sie näher zu mir
sind
man könnte sagen am ende soll sich alle
menschen auf der erde so behandeln wie
meine enge familienmitglieder oder sogar
wie mainz selbst oder wie mein körper
setzt aber was nicht dann in diesen
kreisen umschlossen sind sind natürlich
die tiere kommen gar nicht ins spiel
also dieses zusagen global ist ische
sehr optimistische diese einstellung die
haikus hat hat gar nichts mit tieren zu
tun warum weil tiere uns mit cent kg
haben gar nichts mit uns zu tun weil sie
keine vernunft haben und hier sehen wir
die ethische folge von dem was ich
vorher gesagt habe dass menschen und
tiere einfach sehr wohl ähnlich sind
alles was wir machen ist mit wird mit
vernunft durchdrungen
wir können nicht einmal aufs klo gehen
ohne vernunft einzusetzen weil wir
müssen eine fantasie haben das ist sei
der satz große gegenwehr wird als zu
stemmen
das ist alles vernünftig buchstäblich
wenn einer ein holz nie was mit vernunft
macht also das was nicht ethisch
relevant und wichtig ist nur dass mit
dem etwas gemeinsam habe und tiere haben
mit mir nicht nichts gemeinsam
gemeinsam ist aber sehr wenig die sind
man hätte vielleicht sogar sagen die
haben nicht mehr mit mir gemeinsam als
mit stein wurde stocker
also ist sehr hart werden diese theorie
die apple korea haben kommen zu einem
englischen entschluss oder sollen wir
dem gleichen schluss aber durch eine
andere überlegung das wäre eine längere
geschichte aber kurzum haben sie die
theorie dass alle politische beziehungen
und vor allem die beziehung der
gerechtigkeit die akkus
also denkt wenn ich ihr das heißt wenn
ich irgend jemandem was schulte das kann
nur in stande kommen wenn ich mit dieser
handelten person einen vertrag
abschließe
wir müssen zustimmen das ihn irgendwas
gebe und zurück und politische
beziehungen entstehen immer durch solche
verträge
das ist alles was man auf englisch eine
social country-fans dass wenn wir bei
platon ihrem buch 2 der polit er dass
man über später natürlich bei hp findet
wir in einer anderen form bei virgin
wars also diese vertrages theorien waren
schon in der antike gängig und waren
weil haben am weitesten von den
apple-rechnern endeffekt sehr
ausführlich beide produkte zum beispiel
wird es besprochen und dann sagen sie ja
noch mal die tiere haben keine keine
verstand dh unvermeidlich dass sie keine
verträge mit uns machen können das
wencke gibt es keine beziehung der
gerechtigkeit mit ihren wir können ihnen
nichts schulden und umgekehrt
also es gibt die unsere beziehung mit
tieren hat nichts mit gerechtigkeit zu
tun hat höchstens mit mitleid zu tun
oder sowas
aber wir können nie ethische ethische
pflicht den tieren gegenüber entwickeln
übrigens auch menschen die mit uns kann
beitragen abgeschlossen haben
da gibt es auch keine beziehung der
gerechtigkeit das wäre dann die
begründung wird warum zum beispiel die
römer
dann erobern können als sklaven nehmen
und so weiter was damals natürlich ganz
intuitiv war dass sie würden das als
eine gute schlussfolgerung entnehmen
oder einen schätzen weil das irgendwie
für ein römischer leute wäre das ganz
plausibel dann abschließen wollte ich
nur eine leiste schule kurz erwähnen das
ist sind die zyniker von einem anderen
teams begründet
und diese geschichten kennen sie
wahrscheinlich diese versorgen die auf
der straße leben und sich wie tiere
benehmen zb printer öffentlichkeit sex
haben hessens rohes fleisch manchmal
gehen gegen alle geschäftlichen normen
das wort chemiker kommt sogar von dem
englischen wort und korn also die das
heißt uniqa ist sozusagen also die waren
die kunst und philosophen oder die hunde
männer wittmann genau wie soll sie so
hießen ist nicht ganz klar
aber vielleicht weil sich die hunde
genommen haben und ich und abschließen
wollte ich sagen dass das wirklich damit
zu tun hat was ich gerade gesagt habe
nämlich diese diese tendenz in der
hellen sind locity immer das natürliche
nachzustellen weil wenn man wenn man
nicht so überzeugt ist dass wir nur von
uns wesen sind sondern dass wir
lebewesen sind wie andere tiere
und wenn man auch überzeugt ist dass die
normen der gesellschaft künstlich sind
und nicht natürlich sind dann kommt man
zu dem schluss dass das wenn wir uns
dann die natürliche ziele verfolgen
würde
würden wir eher wie tiere wohnen haus
wie menschen das genau was die zyniker
gemacht haben
deswegen haben sie obdachlos gewohnt
haben sie in der gesellschaft nicht
teilgenommen das wollte sie alles sehr
künstlich nicht menschlich das
menschliche ist das natürliche und das
natürlich gipfel für menschen ist
hauptsächlich das was wir mit allen
tieren gemeinsam haben
also ist es interessant weil hier gehen
die techniker und historiker von denen
gleich von den gleichen prämissen haus
nämlich dass man immer das natürlich
hier verfolgen soll
aber während die historiker dann sagen
okay das heißt nur ein leben mit
vernunft für die zyniker heißt dass mein
leben was mehr oder weniger wie das
leben eines tieres aus schaut also sie
kommen zu entgegengesetzte resultate
durch die fast die gleiche überlegung
was interessant ist okay nächste woche
denn wenn der platonische videos
betrachten und ist seine reaktion ab
halt diese hellenistische theorien
beschreibt und greift kann alles was die
story capital gesagt haben also das
nächste woche